this we are days away from the end of
the school year in ccsd but summer can
be a challenge for some families yeah
for students who rely on food at school
local organizations stand ready to make
sure that no child is hungry madison
kimbrough stopped by project 150 and she
joins us live in the newsroom with the
story
project 150 has provided so much for
students across the valley and tonight
they are making it known that just
because the school year is ending
doesn't mean their services will stop
school is almost out but project 150 is
in session providing food clothes and
hygiene products for students across the
valley and all they need to show is
their student id and with the pandemic
still in effect and supply chain
shortages it's been a struggle says
community outreach manager stacey
chapter there were a lot of people that
just needed a little hand up to get them
through
and we were here for them there are now
restrictions on buying quantities so
that's been a problem for us because we
can't just run to sam's club or costco
and get the pellets of food that we need
stacy says monday through friday their
facility is open to students with food
distribution being a top priority
especially in the summer months we also
have fresh bags with produce and dairy
as well as frozen bags with meat and
pizza and vegetables so that's a good
contribution to the household they're
staying at skyler goodall a project 150
scholarship recipient says the amount of
help they provide from scholarship funds
to food to clothes made it all possible
for her to succeed i don't know if i
would have been able to actually go at
the speed i did
through school especially with i was in
nursing school it was more expensive and
they really accounted for that you
actually get to shop for your clothes
and pick your clothes instead of feeling
like something's being picked for you i
did sports in high school so a lot of
times i'd get food and i'm assuming it
was through them
and project 150 says they go through
about 400 bags of food per week and are
already gearing up for their back to
school shopping event that's going to be
at the end of july in the newsroom
madison kimbrough live local now